hey about to get into a new interview
want to shout out to our sponsor
Imperial they're giving you a free
that's right free 2 G top shelf pre-roll
with the glass tip that's right
delivered right to your door all right
it's free all you got to do is pay
shipping use the promo code bootleg at
Imperial
extraction. there's a 1.5 gram of
Premium flour plus a half a gram of thca
diamonds loaded up in this thing and
guess what you could get one for free
with the promo code bootleg go to
Imperial extraction. comom it's free you
just pay shipping let's get into the
interview uh hey we got a special guest
on the podcast right now Lefty Gunplay
hey it's the Gun Man famous gang banger
OTR bowling Superstar right here tapping
in with bule Kev man had to come run it
up venture to say He's the hottest
rapper in LA right now best I wouldn't
say hottest rapper in LA I would say
hottest rapper in uh for the Mexicans
you know n see I don't even want to say
that cuz I feel like you got motion like
I'm not talking about just Mexicans cuz
that's boing you win I keep it real
there's some blacks that are way better
than me no I'm talking about you're on
fire right now though no that's cool but
n I'm keeping the gas going let's run it
let's run it I want to be the best in
all California at the end of the day and
that's what I say and I keep a g like
yeah I'm the hardest essay I want to be
the hardest in California period you
know what I'm saying and like uh there's
some blacks that are really really hard
just doing unnatural like me but that's
why I'm working hard and uh it just
comes out all littleit do people know
that my new like a lot of my songs I
freestyle like 90% of them I just on the
first try just so that's your like
process of writing you don't write
you're just off the top good I'm just
good at it just really good at rapping
yeah put 100 Bands on the table for
whoever thinks they could get ESS rapper
thinks they could get more views than me
I'll put the money on the table 20 bands
20 bands right now we post tomorrow
night and uh or you post today and try
to beat the grief full star from scratch
Lefty Gunplay by you're probably going
to get discouraged after seeing the
numbers so like I'll put 20 bands on any
essay rapper they could do better than
me I think I'm the best like I really
think I I really would put 20,000 I'm
not capping take the 20 bands I'm not
capping I'm the best I'm going win the
20 bands back like dog there's nobody
you're not going to [__] me over we go
to the same room nobody buy no followers
nothing dog post the same day boom you
post whatever you want I'm going post
whatever I want I'll post talking and
get more views than you onest set like
it's just like that I saw you just
challenged uh Swifty do $100,000 was it
a song battle or what is what is that
who Swifty blue I don't know that fool
you know Swifty blue he was the boy dog
you know what I'm saying hey he's the
homie man I [__] with Swifty Swifty is
my dog you know I don't [__] with him no
more dog like he just like he's cool dog
we used to be boys but you know what I'm
saying [__] changes dog friends switch
up friends switch up in real life [__]
changes rap stupid [__] rap just it's
just like you know he was the boy you
know what I'm saying I come in loyal you
can't be loyal in this in this game like
just [__] like that like I got carried
away but like he started it [__] him on
a said [__] him he started it dog like
you know what I'm saying I used to rap
gramy though you could edit it I used to
R grimy re CU he was the boy he was the
boy it's just I don't want anything to
do with it and I I'm going leave it at
that well I think that uh the productive
way of solving let's give him his
attention real quick no no no I want to
say G attention I I want to tell you
that the productive way of solving any
sort of issues is a song challenge like
you challenge for 100 that's a that's a
way you sol issues that's a peaceful way
of doing it whoever gets more views [__]
wins and you stop rapping but see that's
how [__] should be settled between
artists no Street it's a competition
it's about the music hey hey hey Tri I
don't want I'm not saying I'm I'm I'm
going smoke you know I'm just saying no
I'm saying but that I think that that
was a dope that's a way you settle
things right [__] him he ain't going to
take it though yeah he going to take it
but he said I copied him I copied you my
boy you I ain't nothing like you dog
like I'm a [__] fool dog like I never
copied anything about you dog you hard I
know some of the songs but I never
copied him I don't think I rap like him
right I don't think he's better than me
I think you guys have different styles
for sure my boy I'm the best I came out
I've been out 30 days and look at me I'm
I'm I'm I'm better than all them dudes
like I'm better than a lot I'm home to a
lot but run it up I love the competition
run it up like how we going to be all
rapping we can play teams real quick and
see who what what better team run it up
put the money up gambling I love to
gamble like gamble like I got money on
this dud D that sh will sell out you
know what I'm saying it'll sell a lot of
money and I want to just I just want
everybody know like I am the best like I
I'm the best dog right now in a moment
when you were locked up did you hear
about um when greo and RJ took over the
novo and those are best those are like
the legend blacks no but I'm saying
thiso RJ no hey greo RJ Draco no greo RJ
drao Conrad from the ab um be sad 1900 I
got a song with be sad um just people
like Pac-Man The Gun Man from OT like
you know what I'm saying shout out to
crib like X4 to M Lord like uh those are
just dudes that are just like like
really good at rapping just do such
nonchalant like shout out to zo zo s is
the best yeah zo's fire zo's my boy and
I'm just saying cuz you're my friend
he's just like all around he got that it
Factor no I want to be more like zo I
really do the way he carries himself but
the ESS version I don't think I ever be
like that he's just that he's just that
guy man I'm just [__] stupid and K
just turned up and just like baz I'm
just got it all in one package and just
carries it like humble like just player
about it you know what I'm saying just
me like I'm just I just go with the flow
s just like every beat he gets on his
West Coast la like he Mak some bangers
right he hit him with that underrated
like I would put money on him that he'll
beat me right with the underrated that
that song was it dog that song took over
La for a minute like he did some
legendary things with him I got songs
with Zama yeah like I talk to him every
day I'm on his page right now like
that's the homie he's like my friend
yeah I don't never put him in a
competition cuz he's already like that's
my boy already like he's just like man I
throw him first every time on the set
how I was going to say uh how much of
like you honing your rap skills happened
while you were incarcerated or were you
rapping prior to you getting locked up
when you were 18 like cuz you're really
good at rapping you're not like you know
like you really are dope were you were
you like rapping a lot in jail like I
freestyle my [__] but that's what I'm
saying like that you you you're really
good at that so I'm assuming were you
getting your reps up while you were in
in prison like just rapping in yeah but
I ran out of those songs ASAP so to ever
whoever wants to rap like don't use
those first raps on like the first beat
when you get out your your best bangers
don't use them on a beat that you didn't
[__] fully invest in that you didn't
write it to cuz if you're in jail I
wrote no I write raps in jail with my
head without a beat without a beat or I
remember a song on the radio like like
the and it'll be in your head it'll be
in my head I could remember real
[__] well is that knockout so
be like what is bootle kid up in this
[__] and I'm a knock out call me left
the gun plate I don't [__] with dropouts
so just I'll write it in there and I'll
make it and I'll just go back and forth
it's just crazy in the writing process
writing a song it's just I wrote all my
songs and uh I memorize them after the
first try but there's these one songs
like you write in their bangers and when
you get stuck on a rap song If you ever
made a rap song and you don't buy your
stuff you make a rap song when you get
stuck you get stuck forever H cash you
get stuck huh when you get stuck writing
a song you get stuck forever you never
get past that being stuck part huh
you're so stuck you erase it like a
thousand times like with a certain song
that's why
freestyle just off the top cuz the first
one's the best one not anybody can do
that anymore man that freestyle [__] is
a real gift it's like throw me on the
they're going to throw me on the tler
CER yeah I'm going to go against the
best uh shout out Toppers no I'm going
to win it I'm not going to be part of it
we're going to win it La lefty gun play
is it a competition it's a competition
why would you want to lose the dard
cipher I didn't I didn't know I thought
it was just everybody was rapping n hell
no they pick a winner do they yeah did
you see the little white dudo who did it
a little SE though I seen what tut2 G
won in from OT and he beat M forign uh
shout out you so and K Band and and you
know tut2 G and San Diego won this for
OTR I seen that one how did you uh
that's one of my favorite videos Man
shout out shout out 22 G F man that song
Hard it's a repeat you got to look it up
on the ther Cipher it's called 22 g f d
Cipher for you heard 4 L he hard too I
was going to get a feature with him he
hard too he those guys could sing man
both of them man On's black ones like
Filipino ESS I don't know what he he he
on black ones like you know and they're
both the best singers ever I remember
asking him like hey man how do you learn
how to sing on 22 G he's just like I
just [__] shoot
it hey I thought I was in trouble he's
all I asked G I told him what's up man
at the little weirdo concert I walked up
to him before I sound with OTR I said
man you sing hard man and I'm serious
I'm just like you got any tips for how
to sing better and he's just like I just
do that [__] F I'm just like what the
[__] like damn like that's a lefty
answer but it was just like he was just
cocky like I just do it and it's just
true you just do it you can look up on
Google and find Tips but if you know how
to sing you're talented you know how to
sing dog you know what I'm saying I want
I want to I want to sing I I want to
singing I just think that's what said
the flowing gang [__] and it just so
you're going to start singing eventually
I being singing if you don't pay
attention I guess I'm not enough good
enough singer but I want American Idol
recently I'm [__] with you
he I missed the [__] out of that hey you
like the voice for American
Idol I mean I I never really watched the
voice so probably American Idol American
Idol who's the host on that [__] Brian
Crest and no hell no still yeah is it
still Luke Bryan and no lion Richie
liono Richie is the new one yeah and
then uh all the ogs are gone they used
to be like oh let me get it it's Lio
Richie and then it's man Rebo MC Katy
Perry Katy Perry right and then it's one
more Neil oh that's that's Jennifer
Lopez the dancing one I know this cuz of
jail like in jail I watch a lot of TV
so what all were you watching in
jail um football on Sundays uh two bro
girls in Pelican Bay two bro girls two
bro girls is fire yeah um who would have
thought Modern Family but I Modern
Family is great I did so much time I
seen every episode three times Modern
Family my favorite episode is when she
comes home and they're throwing a party
and the uh that F Phil he's all faded he
smoke weed and they go in and he has
like the alien [__] I Love Phil and I
love [__] and Al Bundy in that show
what's oh they don't get that show right
there I get Bay watch at night time on
my late night Thursday I stay up and I
watch bayw watching uh the four yard
just and night Pamela Anderson Carmen
Electra that's part that's part of my
bars I said blue check mark F face
Carmen elect so if you were locked up
watching Baywatch are you able to you
know Shine the helmet while watching
Baywatch in your in privacy N Hell No
cuz I got my right there and if my did
it I'll trip on my like what's up F like
what you doing you know say do you get
porn in there like or is what want tell
you advice yeah somebody told me in
there they'd be like and I I live in t
there's certain things a man keeps to
himself and that would be and I just
keep it real that would be like you know
Jackie KN oh oh no listen to this um
getting high right um your Dirty Work
cheating on your female or talking down
on your wife just certain things family
stuff that's what I do that's why I just
stopped it I'm like boom I stopped it
bam I'm not even you're the boy you're
the but I just know my mom everybody's
part of me like I just do it and I live
by that like some D some don't some do
want this and some don't yeah I act a
fool and I'm stupid whatever I have a
good time but when it's time to be
serious you have standards I'll shut it
down no I got no standards oh okay I got
no standards straight up I'm like ghetto
but I'm just like I'm smart I'm just
raised Street knowledge and just what
they taught me just I cont take at all
the times always cool I kick it and I
like to have a good time I don't like to
be serious I like to feel I like to feel
comfortable and just chill but like with
all the cameras on and everything I'm
going everything goes on the media site
if you watch to this Mexican platforms
and that's cool but the way they twist
it and I just like yeah I got I do got a
little bit of I got no standards never
mind I was thinking about it do I do I
strippers and ghetto girls my boy I
loved and I don't call him strippers I
call him dancers that's how you know I'm
from the hood we call entertainers
dancers professionals if you be like you
stri you be like n i dance though like I
love dancers F like those are like the
baddest you know girls to me the dancers
in the SUV go crazy they really do hey
what's up with my in what's hey what's
the strip club to go to in the sgv
sattin paradise
Bliss sattin Paradise Bliss is open
after those Clos sattin paradise and
Bliss yeah
sattin Paradise Paradise first then
satting after Paradise while the Sun's
still up like
7:00 go up in there that's the day shift
spot go [__] real quick it's open all
night but I rather go up in there in the
in the daytime you say you go take a
[__] at the strip club throw a gang of
money oh okay okay let them know it's OT
r r bowling
Superstar yeah up in there always lefty
gun play on the game shout out to Dolly
Sandy uh Mac baby do whatever whatever
the hell are these dancers names yeah
shout out Lucy too on said that's my
baby right there she worked there too
she quit right there think shout out to
knockout in a month or two are these
their real names or their stage names
these are their real names to me
I these are the real names to me [__] I
want to know her do you ever have a
stripper tell you or a dancer tell you
their name and no I already know their
name when I walk in there I know who
they are already I go in there that's n
you're not Mercedes you're Rachel I know
you're Rachel no no no I go up in there
and I just know who I want already like
from the gr from IG ig's vicious social
media is vicious like I you find someone
on IG and seek them out falling in love
with them strippers over a picture real
[__] looking at like d she bad shout out
P FL us Finance too on to set it didn't
work out but we'll flirt and stuff and
it's just like yeah ig's vicious are
like with with my schedule now it's just
hard to hard to go do it but I be
managing it like I said man I was
kicking with a stripper last night I was
kicking a stripper night before that
like the girl I'm love with is a
stripper like call them my dancers like
my baby mama was a stripper like my
first baby mama used to try to work at a
strip club like I love strippers like
they're beautiful dog they're bad yeah
strippers are bad homie not all of them
but the strippers in the SUV that are
fine definitely not all of them shv got
some fine ass High straight up shv got
fine High I think shv got some of the
best females in the game shv got pretty
girls dog I've been to other areas I
don't think they're messing with the SUV
girls shout outs to all the SUV girls we
have to go to the strip club together
they got to drink water out there maybe
they'll come out find some let's go I'm
going to go out there we'll hit the
strip club and we'll take a [__] as you
would what strip club would you go to
whatever you take me to bro what's your
favorite one uh I like your half your
hat sick that's a badass hatot but it's
a fitted I don't like my favorite strip
club is not in La it's in Arizona it's
called Jaguars ah he ran with that one
huh I G him the play about the Hat
Arizona I like that [__] though his
Hat's bad huh but see the the thing
before I tell you about the shrip clip
thing I told everybody like they get me
a hat right now when you get a fitted
hat sometimes yeah it's your size but
you put it on and it just if you're a
man dude you know it don't feel right
but then that one Dusty hat that it is
your size you had for a long time and
that's your good luck hat you put it on
It just fits on your head perfect oh
yeah but it's they're both the same size
but the one that you broke in so it's
hard as just get that one is just like
that's it that's your hat you know want
the fitt you know want the fitt it's
like that's the one this one fits
perfect you can't tell me [__] but see
that's the thing with snapack Snapback
always gets me right you know what I'm
saying just Snapback is cool I like
Snapback like shout out to Snapback I
don't I don't [__] with fitt it no more
I really don't I don't like fitted hats
what's your hat size if you were to buy
a fitted my Q is a th000 so my hat size
would be what
10 no like mine's mine's seven and a
mine s and 38 that's my I want to try it
on but I don't want to give my [__] that
I got on my head for yeah I don't know
if you got Li I got money on my
head mind money on my mind no money on
your mind not onone my I get money when
I get head my bad there you go you get
money while you get head man I just got
out of jail man I'm just you know fresh
out just living it up like I've been
locked up my whole life I'm just having
a good time was I don't care about I
don't care about the comments I don't
give a [__] like you know what I'm
saying I don't care what people say like
I'm going everything about according in
the right way like you know what I'm
saying I am from I am I'm from you know
a gang I'm from La I'm proud of I'm a
ESS I'm Mexican you know what I'm saying
and and I've been through some things
and uh you know what I'm saying I don't
care about this [__] I don't care
honestly this real [__] I don't care
about the rap I don't care about the
fame I don't care about the money I just
want to be happy and you know what's
going to make me happy more money and
strippers more money fool more money you
think so I think I'll get happy when I
got more money strippers make me happy
but N I want more money I just don't
ever want to go back to being broke and
poor and just the way that I'm living
like it ain't cool I'm dying to get the
[__] up out the hood does it feel good
to get legal money hell no cuz my child
support going take it I want it under
the table on a said real [__] I ain't
capping he said he going to sign they
off money go to the bank no yeah no I
want I want I yeah she going yeah hell
Noah Char support is going to take half
what back pay so just so we're clear
Char support's grinding if a family
lawyer is watching this you're
technically a broke man and these are
fake chains my boy I don't care about
any Court ticket I don't care if the
contract gets me I don't care if
I do the time in the county what they
going to take but you don't have any
money right I got a gang of money I got
a lot of money I do I got money I got a
lot of money I'm trying to help you out
right now I want to see who has more
money in their pocket than me right now
and I'm not put counting
solers I want to see who wins everybody
in the room that's AER B I don't have
any cash on me man you might win though
I'm fing it all right then I don't carry
much cash I win you win I saw the money
you stuffed in your P I'm humble about
it man I've been broke my whole life man
I pop it I never had [__] you know I
never had nothing what was the for you
like getting out and like kind of
glowing up right away like how did you
get on uh so and otrs I seen it I seen
it I rad I I got out of Pelican Bay and
uh I hit up OTR right away and cash knew
I was going to rap you know King cash
too and just I always wanted to be from
OTR just seen it OTR was just it's OTR
like just growing up that was just OTR
like for the hood that's like that's OTR
like they're just like they blow up all
artists you know what I'm saying they
got a pretty solid lineup I said I'm
going be from there so I hit him up but
I read in the Gucci Man book and it's
some real advice you don't got to tell
me your homeboy's hot you don't got to
tell me that your homie's popping and he
knows how to rap because if he was
popping and he knew how to rap I would
have been heard about him and right now
I'm on everybody's [__] Explorer and
everybody's feed and everybody's YouTube
I'm on everybody in all LA's stuff you
cannot lie and say you ain't see me you
ain't see me you asleep under a rock you
probably missed it I'm everywhere right
now it's ridiculous I'm I don't even
notice I'm passing by I'm in a store on
a sticker in a store crazy story a
sticker yeah on the warehouse shoe sale
my pictures on the side for Street wise
finish story what' I say Gucci Man book
I read the Gucci Man book you read the
Gucci book yeah you don't got to tell me
your homie's hot your homie's popping
your homie knows how to rap your Beats
are hot if your beat was hot I would
have wanted your beat if you if you were
popping soless would have been looking
for me you popping so I'm popping now
you know I'm some type of way and now
OTR is reaching out see me like hey like
and now they see the message back then
it's a funny story so I just manifested
the whole situation and now I'm OTR and
yeah I was doing it by myself I was
getting 200,000 with a iPhone but no OTR
just and cool people say oh he got room
whatever nah it felt right it feels like
family he does everything for me
Atlantic anybody ain't going to do this
for me and hold my hand and just take me
to the top and put the actual love and
support and just believe in your music
that's what I want and soless believes
in it and that's why I'm I'm smoking the
competition in La I'm really money now
but he just he tells me in the car all
the time like you want this you know and
I sit there like looking at him like
what the hell like this some movie [__]
and I was just like do I want it like
you know what I'm saying do I deserve do
I want it and yeah I want it but it's
just like my life's changing so quick
and he's a big part of it cash too like
it's just like it's happening so fast
it's like a perfect game it's like
everything I ever wanted it is it really
is man once you're hot and your your
schedule's just locked in You're Just In
Motion I don't even know where the hell
we're going they just take me here and I
be like oh I remember this podcast from
when you know when I first started and I
was broke I remember looking at this one
this is it I'm here now cool I seen it
in my dream you know what I'm saying I
seen it in my vision type of stuff God
put it in my head cuz that's my vision
he didn't put it in my mom's head your
head your head your head you know how to
rap he got a gang of chains on huh
they're loud God damn he got a gang of
chains on let me bro fool you heard that
[__] you probably could have heard it
from right there that [__] sounded like
somebody moving a shopping C and it was
a gang of gold chain it did sound like
that Jesus Christ that's a that's just
heavy huh oh man that's cool he [__] on
everybody in the conversation hey we got
to stop the interview real quick man
shout out to our family at my bookie NFL
season is winding down you still got
some regular season uh games you can get
in on of course the college bowl games
are coming up so much money to get plus
the cash priz is going down in their
weekly blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh mybookie is crazy cuz
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at mybookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$1,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course of course the
best odds anywhere online when it comes
to your sports betting needs so one more
time sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet anytime anywhere with my bookie hey
uh thank you for watching also shout out
to King pom geez I'm just swimming in
King pom but uh we got a shout out to
our good Folks at bluechew that's right
bluechew.com man New Year time to get
that uh that dick of yours in order
maybe you're dealing with the rectile
dysfunction stress at work maybe you're
married 30 years into the marriage it's
a little hard to get it up for a wifey
over there but you want to you know
smash her uh down take her to pound town
real quick for the anniversary what I
suggest you do is [__] with some
bluechew that's right blue Chu what is
it does it work first of all of course
it works yes it does work I've used it
it's great uh with that being said blue
CH it is the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Calis all right trust me oh
they hit all right in a nice chewable
form yeah and it gets delivered straight
to your doorstep discret packaging you
don't got to worry about going to a
doctor's appointment sitting in an
office and speaking with some stranger
about the issues with your Johnson it's
all online all online if you're asking
well I don't know man this sounds like I
don't know I you know how much is it
what do we got to do to get it look it's
free that's right free you can get your
first month of bluechew for free right
now all right your dick deserves it
whoever's taking your dick deserves it
it's be honest all right so go to
blu.com use the promo code bootleg right
now and guess what your first month will
be delivered for free all you got to do
is pay $5 shipping blu.com promo code
bootleg get your first month for free
delivered right to your doorstep and
thank me later all right let's get back
to the interview well I was going to ask
you like uh I do think that at times in
Latin hip hop it feels like because
they're isn't like a super popping
Mexican rapper nationally yet that when
someone starts to pop the Divide starts
to happen I don't care about I'm just
like let me finish my let finish my
point let me finish so like like an
example would be like uh the homie from
Houston that Mexican OT he's hard he
ain't Cali popping like he just so out
the no he's in Houston popping he's the
best rapper in Houston he he's the best
ra but let me finish my hey my bad
before I say it no no no I got to get
out the way cuz I already spoke on him
like I'm talking [__] about him no he's
the best rapper and everybody says he's
the best Rapp before I forget my bad
it's his podcast I you want to get it
right cuz you're going to twist it n
hell no I want to feature with him
that's my dream collab he's the best
rapper I never seen nobody spit the way
he does not real homie my point was no
but I just want to get it out the way
before it goes on it and be like I'm
talking [__] on no you're saying
something positive about it yeah he hard
he's super hard he hard and I can't wait
to go out to the Houston okay my bad now
your point it's your no my point was
that I I noticed that now that he's
starting to pop that's a viral moment we
got to edit that [__] I should have done
that there there's a whole lot of
negative energy from the other Mexican
artists in Texas towards him and I feel
like a lot of times in La whenever um a
Mexican artist starts to pop everybody
starts turning turning against them like
I saw like this I like this well I saw
this happen with like Kook and CNG like
they beefed out when they would have
been better being together like I mean
you know what I'm saying like I want to
get it already like to me if you think
of uh you're you're on fire I love K sh
cook one man yeah I know you guys work
together for sure my boy but what I'm
saying is like I feel like for the sake
of like putting on a Mexican for the
United States as a rapper it's like the
the unity's got to be there oh GG oh
exactly OG and if you notice ogz don't
like he's always he's always extremely
positive you don't ever see him wrapped
up in any of the negative [__] shout out
to O we got a song together man he
worldwide man you cannot say you never
heard he's the best but my question to
you main with it is that something you
think about like let me try to kind of
like no no uhuh at all I always keep it
real to myself you like it cool you
don't fast forward why just mean in
terms of like trying to no I got to I
got to go mainstream but I don't give a
damn like I just want to do it from I
make music cuz I love make music I don't
want nobody to Tain or change my steo
and it does happen you diss a certain
rapper they try to twist it that way
with that Keen little G incident you
know what I'm saying but I still solid
and I didn't mean it that way but I do
think that I'm the best and he's the
best dog so they try to twist it they
may do whatever they did out of it but
you got to get it right like I don't
care like I'm just doing it for La
that's what I do music for for La yeah
for La for Los Angeles cool if they
listen to it out of town cool they feel
me so I don't care damn I'm not going to
lie to them I make it for la la for
essay and for blacks I make la music I
want people in La I don't care about the
radio I want people in LA to get in the
car on a Friday and go bump that lefty
gun play yeah that's all I care about
it's just like making music where I'm
just letting it out everything I see my
raps are real like I meet a lot of these
rappers dude and they're not like that
in real life and it's like it breaks it
breaks your heart cuz like you look up
to them you know your there's certain
ones that are like you know they're
they're like that and just like now
since I'm doing it it's just like
happens so quick and it's just like it's
it's overrated it ain't what I thought
it was it's cool shot I saw the fans and
[__] I'm going to keep making music but
it ain't what it [__] the fame like you
know what I'm saying like forget the
money the money you get the money is
cool whatever I got money you I I a
happy I got a couple I never had a
couple thousand 100,000 in my life you
know what I'm saying I touched the
100,000 ghetto fresh on nine nine B
touch 100 touch how you say rapping you
ain't even touch 10,000 I'm touching
that it's cool it's like now what like
it's like still not happy I wonder what
the hell it is and it ain't drugs it
ain't being in jail like I wonder what
it is like I don't know what's going to
make me happy like it's just emotion dog
OTR keeps me like a family dog and like
I don't care about uh any other state
but just LA and just making rap for like
the homies dog and the homies are the
main on that hate on me dog so that's
what I want to tell you I want to break
the barrier and I don't think it'll ever
get broken just with like the way that
the comments are with Mexicans hating on
Mexicans but like they're so quick to go
and jump and support like and me too I
love black songs you know what I'm
saying I love black art I want I want
songs with black artist black artists
are my favorite but I'm always going to
support a Mexican I I will sign with a
black label I will sign with a Mexican
label I sign with any label whatever
shout outs to the blacks shout outs to
the Mexicans and La if you know you know
but I'm going to go with a Mexican
artist cuz I want to see the homie win
well there's so many Dope Up and
cominging artists right now there's
obviously they're not wi they're not
breaking that barrier hom I'm saying I
mean but they're on the come like
Coyote's dope um stare hard I Bravo I
never heard of him I heard of Bravo you
never heard of coyote the two brothers
never they're hard are they they're fire
I don't know if I'll check that out I
keep it real but I heard of Bravo the
bag Chaser J band I heard of Bravo he
reached out to me we got a song together
shout out Bravo bra cash you send that
song of Bravo yeah we got a song with
Bravo and J B we going to do a song uh
it's called Holyfield on the gang Bravo
the back your lefty gun J B those are
like they're they're doing it they're
like Hood Rich I'm curious cuz I I I'll
notice like the songs like you pick to
rap over like that are old school like
the game start from scratch and Eminem
to Superman freestyle what were you like
growing up bumping like what were what's
your like top three or four favorite
albums of all time um the game the one
with the hater to love it how the
documentary 50 s Richard D trying yep
and
uh man let me see probably Dr Dre 2001
but if I had a go I would to be debating
on it I would probably get a a a drummer
boy CD straight out the line that one go
hard homie in it I'll get a drummer boy
CD too that CD go hard straight out the
line shout out Drummer Boy man that
homies that see you go crazy or Mazy one
BL the first one nah I would get the CML
LV D [__] heavyweight tank That's my boy
I can't do that I want him with
heavyweight tank more I can't do that
it's like somebody doing a song on my
I'm going get it with heavyweight tank
he got some [__] every day before I get
ready I bumped that uh a plane for kees
that [__] go crazy and he [__] know
excuse my name you you wouldn't do a
record with Mazy I rather do it with CML
okay cuz that's my favorite rapper CML
if I bump his music I would do a song
with Mazy Ma's hard he's one of the
greats in my opinion I wouldn't switch
up though cuz CML reached out to me
first I wouldn't I don't care about the
fame CML and I bump I bump CML just as
much as I bump Mazy but I would rather
ring with CML cuz he just recognized me
and I just like I bump his stuff every
day before I go home just Hood like that
who cares if it's Mazy that's CML lavish
D he go hard you seen the songs a
million you better ask about your son I
put tags on fees my mama text me she
says she praying for me I text my mama
right back you said I'm playing for kees
huh he go crazy that song makes me want
to go to a concert and just like have
you been to Sacramento yet hell no I
going out there on some with CML we we a
get I'm out of bounds baby on the gang I
ain't going with cheito I ain't going
with them I ain't going nobody I stay
down south I was I was going to say like
if you get booked up there you going to
take the booking or no I'm taking the
straps I'm taking the straps I ain't
going out there I'm way out of bounds I
wouldn't want to even touch grounds
right there oh I wouldn't people on the
blog saying that oh he's disy nor so
what I am disy nor and I would never go
up there I'm not stupid and you would
never come down here well I've noticed
like a lot of the a lot of the ogs are
uniting from the south and the north I
don't want to speak on the ogs I don't
speak on Prison politics prisons prisons
the streets is the streets but I talk
about music we're talking music wise
whatever they got going hey I this
listen to that my politics are different
I don't speak on that so what I speak on
though is music wise people say norel
are better than Southside rappers this
is for music they're not they're not
they're hard I don't bump none of this
stuff you know what I'm saying and they
stay dissing the homies so why is
everybody all but her that I'm saying
[__] them cuz they stay dissing us you
know what I'm saying they stay dissing
us calling us you know what I'm saying
that's cool to each is his own I'm going
make music from my side hey shout outs
ha the world man blue devil I like the
way he puts it he just keeps it real dog
and he makes me see it the way that I
see it but I just can't get the words
out but he just like I would it's a big
topic it's everybody saying Lefty says I
I would never do a song with them I
would never go up there and go to their
side of town and I don't think they
would ever come down south I never seen
nor oh never mind I'm not going to say
nothing it's another subject I never I
never leave it like that my question to
you is uh I know you have been putting
out a lot of videos a lot of singles
freestyles are you working on an album
right now
yeah [__] rap dog I think about it right
there just drinking just looking at it
like of the year of the Year [__] rapie
of the Year Rookie of the Year and I'll
still sell it out that's the album The
album's called Rookie of the Year it's
hard so the album's called Rookie of the
Year Rookie of the Year it's the best
[__] that I ever wrote in my life they
got my sound out of me all the [__] you
guys think is hard hell no you get a
preview with like the grial stuff just
the the the Cheeto flow like those are
like the songs they just add and they're
getting like 150,000 70 80,000 in one
day on YouTube I trip out hey how much
is start from scratch got right now
please will I do it yeah Rookie of the
Year man lefty gun play by OTR records
produced by Z Keys South Trey Mt bricks
all cyers what features you got oh man I
got big sad 1900 I got Drummer Boy I Got
King cash I got1 hours 9,000 that ain't
[__] it's probably more than that that
ain't nothing probably the views ain't
caught up yet you got to look at that
from the YouTube Studio he knows he
knows eras it and that sounds hard I
want to hear now yeah shit's hard hey no
on big sad Lil wo Lil Maru um shout out
to San Diego Shout Out Lil Maru we're
doing the baby I can't keep my eyes off
you and
I'm but he's writing what he's writing
and I'm going I got a thing for the rock
and rock P you and yeah that was the Big
Gemini remix that that beat and uh
that's the song that I told him I wanted
on I see him on it and I think he's
going to do numbers him see when you
when you do that record you got to hit a
big Gemini to get it cleared got to just
remake the beat dog to whoever can make
the beat better memorize it in your are
y'all clearing the Big Gemini sample y
yeah through George New
Mexico yeah it's good that's just hard
That's a classic going do money y'all
got to remake some MB Rider [__] no MC
Magic
[__] that that say baby no I know but
I'm saying you should also remake some M
like did you ever grow up listening MC
Magic all my girls did all my mom did my
mom and all her home girls yeah that's
like the girls and the mom stuff like uh
nah I can't oh yeah I should do it for
the people why not for the culture yeah
for the culture they would really like
that shout out to other girls that grew
up listening to that and I'm like you
should you should do a free hey you know
what we're going to have You Freestyle
before you leave over I'mma pick the
beat let me hear which be we're going to
do neighborhood music a little rubby
yeah I think that'll be hard damn that
was going to be hard to do and like then
some all right or we can do summer
nights that's it no or or neighborhood
neighborhood like that I like this song
neighborhood it's all good we'll get to
that later it'll be right now already
well no it'll be a different YouTube I
Little Rob the other day man shout out
to L Rob man man OT took me over there
to a to a l Rob concert on a Sunset
Boulevard in Melrose yeah um he took me
I met him he was real humble he's just
like real like just a hum you know I in
Sao local too like Sao Sao is cool he's
cool as [__] too he's really cool he's
like gang gang like he's just like Hood
with it like he's just he is what like
he says he's just like he's he's a
gangster sa Bo a gangster like you meet
him in person you be like oh [__] he a
gang he real woman recognize real he he
he a l like he gangster you know I
always wondered is I didn't think he was
going to be like that I he surprised the
[__] out of me he's really like that
like he's just really tripping sa lo I
met him randomly backstage at a y
concert in Arizona before he went to
jail the last time he's cool huh I mean
he was cool yeah he like a homie like
yeah that's s boy local shout out s boy
local and YG 400 uh I was going P slim
man I was going to ask you yeah RP to
slim 400 uh for you like being in the
shoe I wonder mentally what do you do to
not go crazy when you're in that sort of
confinement man cuz I just went crazy to
break you right it did it didn't I
didn't even do that long in there people
did 20 30 years you know I don't want to
say too much on it I did two three years
I got no phone no no soups no n of that
you mentally like are you able to
mentally go on a vacation and remove was
like more boring than Cork and shoe Cork
and Sho I had like a good time in there
Cork and Sho was just like just cool
it's just like it's like you just got to
be ready for [__] but Cork and shoe just
Cork and shoe you just got to go to Cork
and shoe to no Cork and shoe no words
can explain it I've been a cork and shoe
I went a cork and shoe for like you know
young grew up in Cork and shoe 18 19 20
boom transferred Pelican bayed shoe year
and a half boom hit the line but I was
in Cork and
Sho [__] was cool right there dog it's
just like different type of time in my
life like just really [__] me up just
really made me better just I just
tripped out on it I looked back at it
like that [__] [__] you up though like
it's just like it's a trip and made me
who I am and I got no regrets but yeah I
wasn't Cork and Sho has it has it been
hard like how long did it take for you
if you even have it adjusted to like
being out I don't think I could do cork
and shoe over again it was just like
that that that was like that vicious
like you just got to have the heart for
the first time and do it one time and
that's it it's just cork shoe brace
[__] like it's just good homies
and there the homies right there just
real tight but corking shoes just
corking shoe I don't miss that thing I
do not and then how how hard has it been
being now learning how to adapt is that
what you ask me yeah learning how to
adapt uh um being so institutionalized
still being in the hood just yeah I got
a bag I got money but money don't last
forever like you know I took care of my
knes and a right now I got an apartment
and I'm just waiting to sign I don't
know why my mom she's like just lagging
D but yeah just I got to get out of the
hood I'm dying to get up out the hood
like people want to be Hood so bad I'm I
don't want this no more I'm always going
to be Hood to keep a ghetto D to the
hood but man like don't but that's also
where you're the most vulnerable at the
hood is always the hood don't ever take
it for granted dog like you live by the
gun you die by the gun I'm not stupid
I'm really gangster and God already
wrote the script you can't be scared
when you go you go just when it's your
time it's your time and if you're not
asking for trouble you just you know on
your lonely on some gang [__] you be all
right but if you're out there looking
for trouble trouble going to find you
they at homies I don't care what area
you in like you know what I'm saying you
in the county you on the streets you on
in another person's Hood you be popping
it for you you better be walking it like
fool out there ain't playing I don't get
to Twisted people out there ain't
playing I wasn't playing you know what
I'm saying it's it's bad out here in La
too like you know what I'm saying but
it's also good but if you look for
trouble you going to find trouble to the
kids doing it like don't do that like
listen to your mom this is [__] and
and are you do you feel like you're
moving in a way which like hey I'm stay
yeah I'm like like you know you you
don't want you don't you don't want to
end up it hurts back or even dead you
know I don't give [__] though like I
don't care if I ended up dead or ended
up back I don't I'm not doing that I'm
being smart about it I know I got [__]
going on for me for myself but if
something were to happen and that
happened [__] it that's what happened
that's the way the script went and we're
we're doing everything not to do that
and that's the part it's hard of as long
as you're doing those things right it's
hard though no that's why I got to tap
Pat myself in the Bo and back and nobody
get gives me that credit like them two
steps back like not kicking it with the
Hood um not being not selling dope no
more right you can't sell dope and rap
that's [__] cuz you're going to be
strapped serving up sex all day you'll
never get in the zone you want to rap
you got to sacrifice and be broke dog
and write them bangers in jail and just
believe in your dream dog and stop being
selling dop dope's cool selling dope's
cool you I never made past [__]
$500,000 in my pocket to where I was
just breaking even every day and just
you know had a brand new shirt and a
chain and a beamer I had a beamer you
know what I'm saying but a haircut but
nothing no real wealth nothing that's
the same thing every weekend I haircut
that's all I have but I had money though
right but now I got money hey we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
good folks want to give a shout out to
odd Soxs that's right baby go to oddsock
official.com they just celebrated 10
years 10 years of odd Sox that's right
use the promo code bootleg right now
you'll get 20% off all right look they
got all the socks they're the most
comfortable socks in the world though I
actually like to point out that that's a
fact uh well it's also factually my
opinion but I am telling you you won't
find a more comfortable sock than Odd
Socks now the real key is guys the odd
Soxs Basics these right
here these are the only socks on my feet
if you saw me um on NBA young boys couch
with some wet dusty ass snow ridden sock
it was a white odd Soxs
basic the most comfortable sock in the
world they got all the licenses they got
[__] Crush they got Baja Blast Beav
and Butthead Hot Cheetos Modello I mean
uh Scarface we can go on and on and on
they got the underwear they got it all
look if you like A1 steak sauce they got
a pair of drawers for that ass go to
ooof official.com right now use the
promo code bootleg save 20% off a
checkout thank me later also want to
give a big shout out to the good folks
of King pal that's right baby if y'all
don't know about King pal let me tell
you about King pal bro first of all
we're talking about straight raw organic
goodness hand me a box Cyrus hand me a
box give me a box oh my goodness look
what's dope about King pom is no tobacco
straight organic natural Leaf all right
oh we got more oh we got more oh these
are the dragon fruit King sizes Jesus
Christ how much King P my [__] god
King Palms
listen that's all we smoke out of all
right and they got the turpine infused
tips with that flavor listen bro the
flavor let me just show you what that
looks like like this right here is some
of that blue
grape you know you light that up you
maybe put put some of your favorite
premium uh whatever you want in there
you know you light it up you got the tip
you squeeze that bad boy you're getting
hit with a rush of flavor um and right
now 50% off when you go to King pom.com
and use the promo code bootleg they got
Grinders they got uh what else do they
got they got goddamn ashtrays they got
all the all the King Palm leaves in the
world my favorite though right now I do
love the sugar Shan the sugar Shan honey
orange is fire all right 7-Eleven you
can go get King palom at 7-Eleven you go
to your local lior liquor store and load
up on King palom it's a clean way to
smoke it's a great way to smoke it's a
natural way to smoke tobac free straight
Leaf in it um I will never smoke out of
anything but a king pom for the rest of
my life all right so shout out to King
pom go to king pom.com one more time
promo code bootleg save 50% off at
checkout half off what are we talking
about let's get back to the interview
well I'm curious cuz I watched your Vlog
you did with duno where you guys were in
in your area which which was dope duno
man great guy love duno most Mexican
person I ever met for real that's on he
should put that on a on a t-shirt make
that's a merch La huh um but I'm curious
cuz like when you were locked up he's
humble man he's a humble guy do know for
sure what like do you remember hearing
about nipy passing away and how he
passed away when you were incarcerated
yeah I do I remember that day nipy was
my favorite rapper I wish I could be
more like I'm nothing like nipy his mind
was just sick like I said I want to be
the Mexican y but like nipy was just his
mentality and the thing that he did the
way he made all money in grinding all my
life all that just just legendary best
rapper top three one of mine top three
rappers all time
nipy
Eminem probably the game probably not
yeah dog man spanu homies on the gang
huh those fools are hard you know they
are hopefully I'm your favorite rapper
top how name top three all time Eminem
nipy Hustle the
game those are good three Tupac's hard
too but n those guys number four I'm
going with the game
nipy so if you the third one Lefty
Gunplay if you and wack end up doing
this fade you just challenged him to on
a on community he's not going to do it
man if you win you get a game verse you
know what man you know what I'm going to
say like this I don't think he knows
like he did let me tell you like this I
got it I don't think he meant it like
that n whack's a good dude bro no that's
cool and I give it I give every person
the benefit of the doubt but like like
yeah I clown around F but like I'm not
playing out here like I don't give a
[__] for like
I'm really from where I'm from I don't
care about this [__] like I'm from a
gang and I got my homies behind me and I
don't care if somebody's dissing me I'm
going diss him I don't think he meant it
that way that's why I'm not taking it
the whole and I'm pretty sure he would
take it the whole way against me too I
know he does I know he does no I know he
does my bad I know he does talk down on
Mexicans I don't talk down on blacks I
do not I've been in jail that's cool I I
don't even know who the [__] he is dog
like I really don't I just did nine
years in Pelican Bay and I I heard who
he had signed he had some artist and
stuff I wouldn't sign with him you know
what I'm saying just I'd be a sellout I
think if you guys met you guys would get
along if he may I'll come at him Embrace
him but I know he's probably going to
you know be like [__] [__] him dog you
know without giving me the benefit of
the doubt so you know shot us to him but
he said like I never shot [__] like he
don't know me dog right you know that's
a good answer cuz I yeah in real reality
yeah I never shot [__] you know don't
but you don't know my life you don't
know what I've been through I don't know
your life I don't know who you are you
know what I'm saying everybody has a
line you know what I'm saying like dog
like I said for you ask for like trouble
I'm not threatening him or nothing but
like I don't give a [__] right you know
what I'm saying like I'm I don't give a
[__] he's he's a businessman I don't
give a he ain't a businessman for saying
that though no but he is a bus but we I
ain't a businessman no I'm not saying
you're trying to do something I'm the
best La rapper this a essay you better
check the [__] resume dog
before you talk about me dog on the gang
I'm really tripping like that Dad homies
I don't give a [__] about this [__] talk
about him like that no I don't talk
about him like that or his people like
that that [__] ain't cool dog I'll never
do [__] with him I wouldn't he's cool
shout outs to him I'll never do nothing
with him dead homies bang that it's like
that I'm tripping like I'm tripping dog
like that [__] ain't cool [__] him I
said it [__] him it is what it is dog we
want to do a show there wherever he's at
[__] him my bad [__] him dog I'm sorry
guys [__] him I'll be letting down my my
people dog [__] him dog I'll be letting
down I'll be a sellout I'd be a sellout
embracing it nah I'm cool cool on him
[__] him I heard what he said let's
change the subject n [__] that I don't
really want to uh finish it up we're
good I'm sorry F they hey so you were
saying on Sunday that's how I feel
though I keep it real I can't go to
sleep with anything bottled inside if
you got feel something on your chest get
it off your chest I ain't fake I'm real
[__] you next question my bad sorry my
bad you going to have to hey let's
lighten it up hey what's your favorite
football team the Raiders the Raiders
I'm sorry they suck huh they barely made
it well you think the problem was I
can't even get back to it after that one
I'm tripped
I feel hot fool I'm too ghetto to be on
this [__] huh I heard what you said my
boy I be a sellout fool shout out to the
S Mexican Community that's a big old
subject I don't do that I love black
people I love blacks I love essay why is
he trying to uh put a put put a line
between it when we trying to break that
right you trying to put a line between
it like make us beef and like I [__]
with blue face you know what I'm saying
I [__] with the game I'm doing a game
remix why you do that dog like I [__]
love Bloods I some cribs dog they're the
homies I'm sure y clear it up no n hell
no he doing it too much dog well let's
get to the Raiders but I'm the first
real I'm the first real I'm the first
real Latino fresh up out of jail 30 days
ago dog and I'm telling you that's not
cool dog it's not right and people are
just saying that it's cool it's not
right somebody with a platform has to
say [__] that it's not cool dog if he
wants to stop doing that and be like you
know what I didn't mean it like that
that's cool we could do it but I doubt
they I wouldn't I wouldn't exchange my
hands to it's not cool he knows what's
right and what's wrong and that's not
right it ain't Ain right and I'm not
cool with it saying I would do it I had
to get it off my chest it's a big
subject you going to go viral [__] viral
it's just real [__] that's not right I
got a platform I'm going speak I don't
like that [__] dog if he wants to do it
to each is his own do it but I ain't
[__] with him dead homies he he
putting a line between the boundary when
we're breaking that like it's about it's
about Unity that's why I was saying
earlier it's about Unity I love black I
just came from a black podcast you know
it's about Unity man I think uh I think
he'll clear that up man she could whack
well I know one thing whack ain't r
I think he is dog I think he is man they
keep asking me I think he I think he is
do you think the Raiders should keep
Antonio Pierce you actually I'm going to
keep a g I don't think he is last thing
fool I don't think he is I think he's
just talking [__] cuz I would say some
[__] if I didn't give a [__] about the
camera but they training so good I think
he's just talking [__] like he don't
mean it like that maybe he don't mean it
like that but it comes out that like
that cuz sometimes I be talking [__] but
I got to watch what I say on camera
right now I'm talking [__] and I don't
think he means it like that I think he
means it like that I think he's just
like so like that's whack 100 whatever
you know he has his artist he's Cash
Money West and he's just like [__] it
[__] everybody I'm just talking [__]
real La [__] you got a long career ahead
of you bro I do that's what everybody
says I got a never mind I was going to
say choke no you no you really do have a
long career ahead of you bro like yeah I
hope so man I really do I really do you
nobody wants to see anybody like you
know the whole thing you know I don't
want to see you crash out you know what
I'm saying or or get yourself into a
situation where no I'm going to be hot
forever that's my biggest dream that's
my biggest downfall I get what you're
saying is to have not be hot and ruin my
career over one thing and it could
happen it could happen at any time don't
take it for granted yeah um and if it
happens it happens F [__] it [__] it hey
[__] it I'm still going to keep rapping
nah bro you got a long career ahead of
you you're just getting started and the
other thing is like you like you could
really like bar out you know what I'm
saying like you really could rap rap for
real for real like yeah you know what
I'm say I'm very impressed by your your
your skill level you know what I'm going
say like this dog like hey dog I Get
High dog like I do drink every day like
I'm [__] in the hood every day I
don't give a [__] fool I'm in the hood
every day like fol don't understand like
what the [__] I'm going through and if
you do cool if you talk [__] cool I
still got more money than you cool I'm
still better than you I still got two
Banos you can't be happy for me I'm
happy for anybody doing it I don't even
know what the [__] I'm saying right now
I'm just saying like so what I'm drunk
I'm high I don't give a [__] I look at
all the and they always say the same
[__] like man oh he's high whatever like
man you sound like a cop every comment
like parole officer like I'm high so
what my mom knows I'm high everybody
knows I'm high they told me to stop I
ain't going to stop I'll stop you know
when when I when I stop what is your uh
you're a drug of choice all kinds of
[__] just everything all kinds of [__]
all kinds of things like I don't give a
[__] like I'm trying catching up to
everybody I'm young for the for camera
purposes marijuana right hell no that's
sh that right now I'm on marijuana
that's why I'm talking this [__] weed is
great I don't even I think we should
edit this weed [__] just gets me like
weed gets me like this fool just dumb
hey weed gets me thinking fool I'm
thinking on this [__] now I got to get
off this [__] I told you get me off here
let me go bounce and go do a
[__] go do let's yeah yeah [__]
go do a little walk all right yo hey but
I give him the best interview I think I
give you a really good interview I agree
brother you're going to edit it right
here and we'll wrap it up at the end I
appreciate you I think he's like looking
at me like [__] Lefty shut the [__] up
like
is EMB I'm trying to help you out dog he
ain't going put in you don't want friend
man okay but tell Cam too hey Lefty he
don't mean no har that's how he is right
you're good like this sure and now
you're good brother hey man I think
you're dope I think the music is dope I
think uh oh don't get this on camera I'm
looking like I'm stressed out I hope you
cut it right there I only want to take a
swig and get it please don't post that
you going ruin my [__] I'll give you all
this not to post that
look
hey
damn I'm going put this one away D I'm
[__] ripping it you know why cuz I
went to the strip club right one my
[__] is a stripper right and she had a
bunch of ones right in her purse but I
got a lot of money too you got P three
bands for a verse in New Mexico blew it
all in two days so look I got money too
he I got money too right so she's right
there and she's just like I'm like hey
I'll trade you 100 for this Hunter I'll
trade you 100 for this hun I'll trade
you 100 for this Hunter just cuz I like
the way it looks it just looks like more
just to talk should come out with a
brick now I'm looking at it cuz I put
the 50s in the front pulled that on my
pocket trying to make a joke out of it
listen and it ripped and it's ripping so
now I'm like putting the 50s bag right
now and I'm going to put them away and
stop showing off what is it I don't give
a [__] it's like what
$1,000 hold on let me see how much it is
I don't care I'm not streaming showing
off I don't even care if we're recording
on looks like you had a nice night at
the strip club from what I can tell
400 these are leftovers yeah these are
leftovers this is what the girls didn't
get off
you 50 look hold on wait up 60 70 80 90
100 100 200 300 400 500 we're doing
banking no wait up no I want to see see
how much I got there 20 30 40 50 60 70
80 900 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 900 20 30 40
50 50 60 70 80 90 100 5 10 15 20 21 22
23 24 25 so look I got 100 200 300 400
500 600 700 800 $825 in my pocket that's
$25 left let's go
baby at least they at least the the
young ladies didn't get all the money
off of you at the strip club last night
noell leftovers for tonight I'm in I'm
in but if I'm now we just got to take
you to Tijana with that I'm not going to
lie no I want I spend it in the
community this community dig it's for
everybody recreational use I I I I got
to throw back get back to the community
right I'm going go to the strip clubs in
the hood yeah for sure right I support
the ones in the hood got to support the
home girls what I say I got I got to get
you I got to get you hooked up with some
blue chw $825 what is that I want some
it sounds like it's a dick pill oh shoot
son got you Blue CH promo Cod bootleg
you get a free month it if it's good
it's much better than a Rhino gas
station dick pill a brand new B oh yeah
we'll get you hooked up on the blue Cho
they'll have you [__] rocked up bro
endorsement deal endorsement deal for
all the sgv strippers bro they you'll be
[__] serving dick like Jack in the
Box tacos at 2: a.m. BR I can't lie like
if I say like every time I [__] I don't
[__] pop a rhino everybody the honey
pack I do on Rhino sometimes it [__]
me up though like my my eyes will get
red when my question you is is it either
or or do you prefer one over the other
you prefer it's in your head yeah
sometimes like it's in your head like
sometimes I just wing it without it f
have you ever popped a rhino thinking
you were going to [__] but then didn't
and then you ended up beating off at
night and your dick just won't go away h
no nah
never that happened h
no like I was talking to RCI once and he
was like we're talking about D all the
[__] Cas show my DM yeah Lo and lo
press a clear all and press open my DM
in front of the camera cash don't open
N Cash no I'm not going to show no n I
just want to show these Foods how my DM
look check it out you you edit them so
when I open it is it going to open on my
page watch I'm going to show you right
now look hold on we're going to go like
this I'm going to go Instagram look here
here's Instagram look okay we're looking
here's my Instagram show the camera I'm
going like this how do I do it on iPhone
I'm going to go like this look I'm go
boom boom boom bo boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom hey how much am I making
on YouTube Studio cash hold on just D
quick how much am I making while I'm
looking for it okay here we go okay
watch you see h h h h h hone honey I see
it look
[Music]
watch that's not the camera it's this
camera h h h honey honey honey honey
honey honey honey hone y hun hun every
time they're all hunters look they're
all mostly women or mostly people trying
to buy verses all types of [__] like
show them the DM show them the DM cuz
like I are you you got to be killing it
right now gu vers I through hitting me
up and you're famous I don't even look
at it SP out I don't give a [__] yeah
[__] rap I got money like show show them
the [__] in your DM look hun hun hun
again I got another one you should go
through and see what famous people have
hit you up maybe you're you're missing
out on a nice feature right now hell no
no hell no hell no hey hell hey my bad
I'm just kicking it think we're kicking
it still hell no hey look I'm definitely
one of the top five artists in the SUV
shout out Lefty gunay I appreciate you
gang who's this talking is this the
homie OJ the sickest C I'm the best uh
yeah shout out uh
[__] oh yeah let me let me see let me
see oh yeah o got an interview that's
right look here's my DM look at my [__]
okay oh man wait on let me see who I got
in here let's
see we better hey we better have some
girls in here look let me see with up
boom bo boom see it all with fat wle
that's my boy right there oh look at
this [__] right here that [__] look
bad yeah yeah lot of women I [__] that
[__] already there you go I [__] her
too look at Ley hit me up wait up Jun
ladin bcv hit me up look Food Network
look okay artist connect Pon F wait up
wait up let me see oh let me see it's
lit in there n let me see one
more I I I see the girls I mean I ain't
seeing the messages but I see you got a
bunch of hoes in your [__] look at this
one stupid young hit me up on a set
stupid young hit you up edit that [__]
though running let's running right now
look stupid young shout out stupid young
what it say stupid young huh yeah that's
the homie come on fol shout out to Long
Beach hey fool I don't want to don't
open it yet cuz I want to read it myself
and answer I want to I want to read it
myself and answer hey I got 925 I
dropped 100 on the floor I'm the winner
okay we're going to take this
$925 and go somewhere hell no but look I
appreciate you pulling up we're going to
have You Freestyle is that cool in a
separate video we'll take a little pause
right now no we can do it right now no
no we're going to take a little
break Rook when is Rookie of the Year
coming hey stupid young hit me up F fly
cripping with that
with
me got get stupid young on my brother
and if you start me you know I'm going
even fools told me young you've been
tripping for no reason wish you not he
bring that pain song Mando I love stupid
young he's hard super hard that's that's
my dream I'm just living my dream dog
yeah that's crazy huh hey man stupid
young hit me up I think that's dope I
think you got a bright future ahead NY
Gunplay [__] on the [__] on the
set I'm I'm really the essay stupid
young damn that's crazy I'm bless see I
would have never expected that
[__] is paying for that [__]
like I'm just doing it with him because
he does it for the music I believe like
me he's just like a real hitter like me
anyways I'm going dog well listen
brother I appreciate you we're going to
get the new album soon do we have any
idea when rookie of the year is coming
[__] I hope tonight be liking it
sometime in February it's sometime in
February it's already done it's already
done sometime in February New
York okay they could have it for a band
right I appreciate you pulling up
brother yes sir there it is can you
believe I have 925 I can't believe I
dropped 100 on the floor hey man come on
man back 100 baby [__] with you can we
show some love to our family at harden
man shout out to harden man look if
you're in Vegas you got to pull up you
got to say take me to harden right now I
need to go to harden they're going to
take you they're going to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Harding Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to
Harding Las vegas.com and when you're in
Vegas make sure you pull up to harden
baby